[Musique]
mondial pêche ce département un débat en
partenariat avec nos confrères de
l'yonne républicaine et vous pouvez bien
sûr réagir et commenter en temps réel ce
débat sur facebook 16 candidats en lice
dans cette circonscription et parmi eux
nos six invités en commençant par jean
yves caullet bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le député sortant vous avez été élu en
2012 sous les couleurs du parti
socialiste mais vous avez rejoint
emmanuel macron bien jeu de la
présidentielle andré libron jours
bonjour vous êtes le candidat investi
par heller et lui dit vous êtes par
ailleurs le président du conseil
départemental de l'yonne françois
meyroune bonjour je vous êtes candidat
pour le parti communiste
philippe collin bonjour bonjour candidat
de la france insoumise dans cette
élection mehdi bargot bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le candidat de debout la
france edwige jaquet bonjour je vous est
la candidate du front national tous les
électeurs ne vous connaissent pas
forcément tous et toutes nous vous
proposons donc de vous présentez nous
dire quelles sont vos motivations
va falloir être con si vous disposez de
30 secondes chacun nous avons tiré au
sort l'ordre de passage et c'est vous
qui commencez françois meyronnis oui
donc je suis candidat du parti
communiste vous l'avez dit membre du
front de gauche soutenue par ensemble et
par les ateliers citoyens de la gauche
migennoise je suis professeur des écoles
retraités toute ma carrière je les fait
en zone d'éducation prioritaire à saint
florentin et à migennes j'ai été élu
pendant deux mandats saint florentin et
j'ai été bien sûr élus à migennes je le
suis toujours mais j'ai été maire
pendant huit ans et demi ma candidature
prolonge la campagne que j'ai mené pour
jean luc mélenchon aux élections
présidentielles je crois d'ailleurs être
le seul autour de cette table un l'avoir
fait je porte un programme de rupture
avec la politique qui a été conduite par
françois hollande est qui
en rupture également avec celle de la
droite qu'elle soit classique ou
maquereau nien jeune couple ne respectez
pas les règles stables mais non j'arrive
puis bonjour donc je m'appelle jean yves
collet j'ai 60 ans je suis ingénieur
agronome génie rural des eaux et forêts
puis je suis devenu préfet j'ai une
carrière administrative assez variés
j'ai choisi d'habiter à wallon dont je
suis maire depuis 2001 et ayant été
député à deux reprises 99 2002 et pour
cette législature j'ai pu mesurer à quel
point nos vieux réflexes partisans et
nos blocages sont pénibles pour le pays
j'ai donc effectivement décidé de
rejoindre emmanuel macron et le projet
la république en marche dont je porte
les couleurs pour cette élection dans la
2e circonscription andré vis des bons
jours et puis bonjour aux habitants de
la deuxième circonscription donc paysans
à la suite de nombreuses générations au
pied de vézelay de la mairie de pierre
pertuis puis de celle de vézelay à la
présidence d'abord du conseil général
puis du conseil départemental
j'ai toujours conduit vie
professionnelle et vie publique de
manière parallèle élus de la ruralité
je suis au service de mes concitoyens
qui me le rendent bien puisqu'il me
renouvelle très régulièrement leur
confiance et fort de ses expériences
réussies je souhaite maintenant faire
entendre la voix de notre territoire
dans toute sa diversité dans l'enceinte
de la représentation nationale ou les
ruraux sont peu représentées il s'agit
là de la première raison de mon
engagement
merci andré villiers philippe quoi oui
bonjour
philippe collin je suis paysan
mais on va dire moi je suis paysan à
plein temps je n'ai pas des mandats qui
prennent une grande partie de ma
représentation donc je le paysan bio
j'ai été engagé depuis le début de ma
carrière professionnelle dans un
syndicat qui s'appelle la confédération
paysanne avant d'en être le représentant
national pendant plusieurs années
et puis j'ai choisi de rejoindre et de
demander l'investiture de la france est
soumise parce qu'aujourd'hui il me
paraît essentiel que la question sociale
soit posée et que par rapport à nos
territoires
on doit vraiment se soucier de donner
des plus que des signes mais vraiment un
changement de politique fondamentale par
rapport à ces territoires abandonnés de
la république que son milieu rural merci
beaucoup mais du barreau bonjour merci
de m'accueillir donc mehdi barbeau
candidats pour debout la france dans la
continuité des élections présidentielles
où j'ai mené la campagne présidentielle
pour notre président nicolas dupont
aignan je présente ma candidature sur la
10e circonscription
je suis marié un enfant j'ai 27 ans et
j'ai toujours été sur le territoire
rural de la 2e circonscription
j'habite aujourd'hui à gurgy je
travaille dans l'yonne pour un grand
groupe de métallurgie et en politique je
me suis investi depuis déjà plus de 8
ans où je me suis présenté à de
nombreuses élections notamment
départementales ou municipales et
régionales dans cette continuité là je
veux faire entendre la voix des
électeurs qui porte en nous un fort
espoir de patriotisme et une droite
forte pour combattre l'adversité macro
nist merci bonjour alors comme vous le
dis je m'appelle jacques et j'ai 35 ans
je suis animatrice artistique et
culturelle chose qui est pas commun
surtout quand les candidates au front
national
je tiens à préciser
certains pouvant dire je suis pas
forcément toujours été dans l'yonne ça
fait 17 ans en fait que j'ai rejoint
l'yonne j'ai commencé mes débuts en fait
dans le val d'oise en tant que militante
et puis je suis revenu près de la
famille parce que c'est important de
noyau familial pour s'épanouir et pour
les enfants
malheureusement c'est vrai que je
constate que notre beau département
comme une grande partie de notre pays
souffre de bien des maux et j'estime qui
est normal qu'il faut aussi un moment
donné s'investir et donc je vais essayer
d'être cette candidate aux législatives
qui sera la seule à proposer une vraie
opposition au système d'un conte alors
vous avez proposé de l'opposition c'est
de vous nous amenez premier chapitre de
cette émission on voulait effectivement
faire un chapitre politique parce que la
situation nationale et finalement
inédite on a eu une présidentielle
inattendue pour certains ça justifie de
vous demander où vous vous situez dans
la majorité ou dans l'opposition je
commence par vous jean yves caullet mais
sans grande surprise pas de changement
non les français ont choisi en l'élisant
emmanuel macron de tourner une page
une alternance mécanique droite gauche
qui finalement rigidifie l'ensemble du
pays
je pense que le programme porté par la
république en marche est une chance pour
le pays c'est un moment un peu
historique pourrait concilier la
solidarité et la compétitivité pour
protéger mieux mais aussi libérer
davantage et il me semble tout à fait
important qu'une majorité claire
permettent de réussir le problème du
pays c'est de réussir de se réapproprier
l'avenir et la fierté de notre
performance de redonner le goût à
l'avenir à notre jeunesse et de d'être
fiers d'être français au sein de
l'europe donc voilà c'est mon engagement
cette majorité elle va affronter de
nombreux défis j'ai envie que notre
territoire nos territoires participe de
cette dynamique
andré villiers vous êtes membre de l'ue
dit investi par l air et du daily mail
udi n'est pas critique du tout avec
emmanuel macron pour l'instant ça vous
situe ou dans une majorité derrière le
président ou dans une opposition
écoutez je vais vous répondre non pas de
manière elliptique mais de manière
précise
la question du 11
juin du premier tour de l'élection
législative c'est pas le problème posé
par emmanuel macron side aventure
c'était un problème et ce n'est pas un
problème sans doute c'est jean yves
caullet je veux pas résumer le débat
un échange avec jean yves caullet mais
je vais être clair et c'est la deuxième
bonne raison de mon engagement dans
cette candidature
je veux dire à jean yves caullet que
j'ai lu ses papiers électoraux ce ceux
d'hier et ceux d'aujourd'hui et ce qui
est étonnant c'est que pendant cinq ans
vous aviez le pouvoir de réaliser ce que
vous annonciez en 2012 et rien de tout
cela
l'heure est donc au bilan et vous vous
dérobez actuellement en mettant dans
votre poche
la rose de 2012 pour vous cap et d'une
nouvelle kazakh
je trouve que pour ma part la ficelle
est un peu grosse ce n'est pas bien
vous annoncez votre volonté de dépasser
les vieux clivages dont vous êtes sans
doute là la parfaite incarnation vous
éprouvez le besoin de dire qu'il n'ya
pas d'ambiguïté d'ailleurs et ça répond
sans doute un peu une question entre
vous et emmanuel macron sans doute pour
mieux vous en convaincre vous déclarez
la main sur le coeur être attaché à la
ruralité mais vous êtes avant tout
citadin on vous voit peu sur le
territoire et quand vous venez sur le
territoire vous ne revenez pas le maire
de la commune que vous visitez vous
voulez mieux protégés c'est ce que je
lis dans vos documents
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir fait plus tôt
vous voulez développer l'apprentissage
vous avez échoué vous annoncez la baisse
des dotations pour les communes
c'est important dont je ne vous
laisserai plus parler après si vous pas
qu'il serait temps
il serait temps de cesser la baisse des
dotations pour les communes je ajouter
en matière de prêts agricoles la
circonscription est une circonscription
agricole vous voulez légiférer pour
soutenir les prix agricoles
vous aviez la majorité vous ne l'avez
pas fait durant les cinq ans qui
présentait atteint 2 faut suivre un peu
je pourrais suivre
l'énumération de vos engagements mais
vous empêcher de le faire mais non mais
comment comment celui qui a
n'a pas tenu ses promesses pourraient
être crédible aujourd'hui voilà pour moi
le débat il est là il est dans la
circonscription il n'est pas sur le
terrain national donc von il est sur le
terrain et vous vous situez sinaï où
opèrent des départements qui parle voilà
je note que les réactions sont bas on
vient y a alors oui la courte
jean yves caullet répondra parce que
sinon il ya quatre personnes qui votent
ramener le débat ne disent rien mais
attendez on y reviendra bien sûr mais
sait déjà que proposition me coller je
ne suis pas forcément favorable à son
bilan mais c'est vrai que je trouve
drôle je dirais que monsieur viguier
face genre de réflexion alors que notre
département souffre de bien des maux
grâce à son travail qu'il a mené depuis
un certain temps donc voilà je pense
qu'il faut regarder déjà ce qu'on a fait
soit avant de critiquer les autres
monsieur madame j'acquiesce les
démocrates les avaient tout perdu les
élections
je vous rappelle qu'il aurait le pouvoir
au département sans doute vous ferez
beaucoup mieux je ferai certainement
beaucoup mieux que vous parce que c'est
vrai que quand on se traîne des
casseroles comme les vôtres on n'a pas
envie d'avoir les mêmes puisque
augmenter les impôts comme vous l'avez
fait ou vous gaver comme vous avez fait
avec les gens qui vous entourent et et
j'en passe et des meilleurs moi je ne
l'appelle pas ça représentait le peuple
et faire les choses pour son bien toutes
choses qui font dire les messieurs c'est
pour le bien du peuple et ça c'est ce
que nous on veut au front national on
veut représenter le peuple et le
défendre on ne veut pas continuer à lui
taper dessus et ils enterraient un peu
plus chaque jour
j'accueille vous faire élire pour sa
femme et ses six candidats par des deux
autres bien sûr et moi je crois que
poser la question majorité opposition
tout de suite y répondre c'est mon avis
se tromper parce qu'en fait tout est
possible à cette élection législative
il peut y avoir une majorité
effectivement qui suivre qui suivent le
président de la république ou bien qui
suivent la droite classique ou bien les
deux en même temps
flanqué de l'extrême droite mais il peut
aussi y avoir une gauche de
transformation sociale qui soit
majoritaire ça peut arriver c'est dans
le domaine du possible
c'est ce qui serait du coup une
opposition par rapport au président de
la swiss assurera tout simplement une
cohabitation ça a existé dans le passé
jst et en 86 ça existait en 97 avec le
nazisme alors que le président de la
république n'était pas du tout de la
même sensibilité politique donc nous
nous battons pour que cette gauche de
transformation sociale soit majoritaire
et nous nous plaçons notre candidature
dans cette perspective si ça n'était pas
le cas et bien où nous serions dans
l'opposition au président de la
république et à la nouvelle majorité de
droite ou maquereau nice tu vois là et
cela pour tout de suite
en tout cas faire échec à aux
propositions du président la république
de légiférer par ordonnance notamment
pour casser le code du travail une
patron forcément ça apaise de réaction
de philippe collin on voit avec un peu
de malignité on a mis le parti
communiste et la france insoumise sur le
même plateau
qu'est ce qui vous différencie de
françois meyroune vous me permettrez
déjà de m'amuser de les changes que
auquel on vient d'assister enivrez vous
voilà entre jean yves villiers et andré
collet parce que j'ai vraiment le
sentiment que au fond aujourd'hui rien
ne les sépare sur le projet politique
dans la mesure où il ya une grande
partie des membres de majorité
départementale qui aujourd'hui ils
rejoignent la république en marche donc
il ya une confusion dans ce domaine mba
j'ai un peu de difficulté
je ne ferai pas de bilan des cinq
dernières années mais tes dix dernières
années je souligne qu'aujourd'hui
l'un des ministres que j'ai bien connue
qui était bruno le maire se retrouve
aujourd'hui en bonne place dans ce
gouvernement
après avoir tout au long de son sa
mission contribuer à liquider une grande
partie de l'agriculture française qui
encore eu beaucoup de difficultés à se
relever donc voilà aujourd'hui l'impasse
sociale l'impasse territoriales dans
laquelle nous ont mené les dix dernières
années de politique donc qui sont à la
fois mené à côté menée sous le
quinquennat nicolas sarkozy que la
deuxième partie du quinquennat de
françois hollande nous amène dans cette
situation où aujourd'hui on a le devoir
d'offrir des perspectives sociales et
pour que les territoires abandonnés de
la république puisque le avoir le
sentiment à nouveau d'appartenir à cette
république de politique quand même vous
regrettez pas ne pas vous être entendu
[Musique]
moi aussi mais va proposer la question
jusqu'à vous posez la question moi j'ai
une petite déclaration d'eau claire
laurent a rappelé qu'il n'a jamais été
question d'accord pour les législatives
en france c'était le 4 janvier 2017 avec
la france a soumis ce qui est mort dit
elle aujourd'hui pour les communistes
c'est d'apparaître nationalement dans
toutes les circonscriptions il faut
aller à la bataille dans un esprit
constructif en appelant à voter jean luc
mélenchon à la présidentielle il ya des
faits pour didot les candidats launay
mois s'est tenue il ya des noms
d'oiseaux initiative non mais excusez
moi donc on peut pas faire l'impasse
vous dis je vous y répondre c'est clair
mehdi barbeau qui attend patiemment au
lui aussi répond clairement à votre
question debout la france a été
et dans la campagne présidentielle s'est
allié avec le front national là encore
vous êtes face à un passé rattrape
on ne s'est pas allié avec le front
national c'est un accord entre nicolas
dupont aignan et marine le pen pour le
second même si mme thibault il ya
toujours le lit de votre leader aux
régionales et toujours avec le front
national
wima c'est bien pour lui cette bonne
route c'est bien pour lui je lui
souhaite bonne route c'était un accord
entre deux hommes d'état qui voulait
sauver la nation de de ce second tour
face à mâcon c'est ce qu'ont fait encore
là au premier tour vient ma candidature
serait 2e circonscription et il ne faut
pas nous assimiler des élèves front
national il ya bien deux candidats
aujourd'hui c'était un accord de second
tour
rappelez-vous mitterrand avec les
communistes quand ils l'avaient fait ça
n'avait choqué personne
on a toujours eu des front républicain
monsieur villiers est très fort pour
faire des front républicain face aux
patriots au second tour et ça marche
oui pour l'instant ça marche mais
maintenant il ya le front patriotes et
il se trouve que bientôt bas
les français seront contents d'avoir des
élus qui les protège via ma candidature
ou peut-être celle de quelqu'un d'autre
parce qu'ils attendent une droite forte
que je vais représenter à cette élection
et que j'appelle à tous les patriotes et
républicains a voté pour nous et
apporter notre programme alors on arrive
et vous allez me regarde et méchamment
si je vous dis ça à peu près à la moitié
de cette émission on a prévu de parler
de vos circonscriptions et on va le
faire avec stéphane vergeade le
rédacteur en chef de l'yonne
républicaine parce que il connaît
particulièrement bien ce territoire et
avec stéphane on va parler des villes
allait entrer stéphane bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ont saisis en
regardant votre circonscription c'est
une circonscription avec un certain
nombre de villes petites et moyennes par
rapport à d'autres circonscriptions
merci passer de viande m'inviter à ce
débat qui est parti sur de bonnes bases
et on apprend d'ailleurs certains et
cette particularité on apprend que
debout la france et par aller au front
national ce qui est assez singulier
mais pour en revenir aux enjeux locaux
parce que vous allez y allez quand même
être élue d'une circonscription tous si
vous voulez temps
on voit que cette circonscription elle
est évidemment à très forte dominance
rurale
cette circonscription agricole vous
l'avez dit mais aussi des pôles urbains
qui ont voté de façon très particulière
aux à la présidentielle on peut en
produire 4 avallon à voter pour emmanuel
macron les deux tours toner saint
florentin migennes ont voté très
exactement la même façon marine le pen
jean-luc mélenchon emmanuel macron au
premier tour
qu'est-ce qui est ce que ça traduit ça
selon vous quel phénomène cette
politique s'est traduit est proposé avec
elle une façon un peu plus provocatrice
pose est est-ce qui et comment on va
réorienter ces villes là vous si vous
êtes élu demain qu'est ce que vous
faites pour réenchanter ces territoires
là et faire que dans ces zones rurales
on n'est plus ce sentiment de relégation
et plus forcément ce vote extrême
aujourd'hui monsieur cole est ce que
vous comptez vous avez réussi à regarder
elle écrit très très rapidement mais on
a une circonscription très rurale avec
quatre petits pôles urbains qui en
constitue l'armature ces pôles urbains
qui est lé pôle industriel conserve des
atouts en la matière à saint-florentin
me gêne un ballon à tonnerre aussi jpg à
des projets mais elles ont vécu la crise
de façon très violente et il faut
absolument justement relancer l'économie
de ces pme et tpe et de ses présences de
grands groupes qui sont importants le
programme de la république en marche
prévoit les allègements de charge de la
formation professionnelle 0 offres
d'emploi non pourvues c'est l'objectif
pour un territoire comme celui là est
bien entendu le plan d'investissement
dont une grande partie pour
l'agriculture trouver des valeurs a
ajouté nous avons des atouts et
l'ensemble des mesures pour relancer
l'économie s'appliquera et donnera des
effets sur notre territoire mais j'en
suis convaincu il faut aussi bien
entendu que la partie sociale minima
sociaux salaire net pour les salariés et
la prime d'activité viennent renforcer
le pouvoir d'achat parce que notre
commerce local a aussi besoin de savoir
d'achat local qui fait partie de la
qualité de la vie donc moi je pense le
programme de la république en marche
s'applique parfaitement à la réalité de
ce territoire qui a été sevré meurtrie
par la crise mais qui est en train de
s'en sortir mais celui des dérivés que
ce programme vous compte à rebours donc
on va pas nécessairement nous en ont
bien j'entends bien
et jean yves caullet le sait puisque
dans les semaines qui précèdent de jeu
les interpeller sur ce sujet en 2015 il
a voté un texte qui est projet de loi de
finances rectificative et dans ce texte
il n'a sûrement pas vu je veux lui faire
ce crédit mais une disposition qui
s'applique à partir du 1er juillet 2010
est qui va empêcher 76 communes du
territoire
rien de moins le tiers plus du tiers de
la circonscription pendant cinq ans de
bénéfices sera réglé dans six mois de
bénéficier de bénéficier des
exonérations fiscales et sociales qui
concerne les artisans les commerçants et
les professions libérales ou d'un côté
on a par exemple programme sampler et de
l'autre la possibilité d'installer des
médecins parce que ils ne pourront pas
prétendre à des aides pour s'installer
donc je me dis que là on marine paradoxe
et ça va être réglé dans six mois
j'en suis forte elle est là où il ya la
zrr il ya aucun problème mais qui
connaît l'entreprise
aucun n'a recensé que les vandales mois
que ce soit réglé dans six mois j'en
accepte l'auguré
monsieur collet et si je suis élu je
prends l'engagement effectivement que
ces 76 communes réintègre le dispositif
dans lequel vous allez dans l'opposition
voudrait pas sur la loi de finances mais
tout serait tout ce qui si je suis élu
tout ce qui sera bon pour le département
après mon suffrage monsieur collet donc
de ce point de vue là je resterai le
participerez à la restauration de
l'équipe et sur ses 76 communes dont
vous n'avez pas vu que votre vote et
bien comporté des effets père est en jeu
a précisé c'était préjudiciable
et je vais vous dire monsieur collet
vous avez écrit récemment à l'ensemble
des maires envers dieu que je m'agite
est un petit peu par rapport à ça vous
avez écrit à tous les maires pour leur
dire mais non vous inquiétez pas on va
arranger ça j'ai dormi dylan situation
que vous essayez d'instrumentation les
six mois qui viennent mais voyez ça fait
mal quand même quand on met le doigt ou
allez c'est pas un débat est tout à fait
symptomatique de la captation qui est
faite du l'élection nationale part d une
confusion totale avec des élus qui ont
aujourd'hui des mandats locaux et donc
il ya quelque chose qui induit un biais
dans ces élections là et au moment où
notamment le député sortant a voté la
loi qui interdit le cumul des mandats
ils luttent et élégant que les les choix
a été annoncé auparavant
voilà je me présente non des élections
législatives
je démissionne donc de mon mandat parce
qu'il est pas normal
après avoir sollicité les délais
suffrages des électeurs il ya trois ans
aujourd'hui de dire ah tiens finalement
j'aurais peut-être quelque chose de
mieux à faire dans ma vie je pourrais
être député ou alors je pourrais
continuer des députés mais je peux plus
être maire d'avallon donc je vais
abandonner mon mandat de maire
ce serait très élégant de le faire
d'abord et il ya ces lâchers d'eau des
jeux je tique
je vous ai écoutés monsieur collet donc
s'il vous plaît merci quand même de
laisser la parole 30 secondes donc je
crois qu'il ya vraiment une confusion
l'ensemble des électeurs et ce sentiment
d'abandon de ce sentiment qui est
aujourd'hui présent chez tous les
citoyens que la politique est quelque
chose qui se déroule en dehors d'eux est
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui génère ce
vote ait su sentiment d'abandon du
territoire de la république
sincèrement vous partagez une somme et
rhône moi je voudrais répondre à votre
question aux défis que pose la question
devrait enchanter les populations et
surtout éviter cette tendance à voter
pour pour l'extrême l'extrême droite
moi je pense que si il y à ce vote pour
l'extrême droite
et bien c'est parce que on ne répond pas
aux besoins des populations
je pense qu'il ya une urgence sociale il
faut absolument que l'on puisse vivre de
ses revenus mais que ses revenus ils
soient à la hauteur et il faut par
exemple augmenter le smic le smic il
faut qu'il passe tout de suite dès le
mois de juillet à 1800 euros bruts c'est
une de nos revendications
il faut que les minimas sociaux soient
augmentés il faut que les retraites
soient des retraites des sens qui
permettent aux retraités de vivre
décemment
il faut par exemple qu'on arrête avec
cette ponction supplémentaire de csg
comme cela a été promis je crois par le
président macron de 1,7 pour cent sur
les retraites qui va frapper les petites
retraites vont partir de 12 cents
oh à partir de 200 euros c'est quand
même une petite retraite
alors quoi être onéreux son garage il ya
il y a exonérations de charges
je vais s'est entretenu ce sont des
cotisations sociales qui participent à
la protection sociale des citoyens
et ça il faut les sauvegardes et moi je
ne suis pas pour qu'on exonère de
charges très bon dit entre guillemets
les les entreprises parce que ça ne crée
pas d'emplois d'accord regarder le cic
eu par exemple on a donné de l'argent
aux entreprises quel est le résultat
si ce n'est la confortation de leurs
marges alors qu'il ya des mesures sans
encombre et des jackets ont beaucoup
beaucoup parce que déjà je trouve ce
plateau voilà vraiment rigolo m'attire
parce que voilà je vois monsieur piliers
qui s'acharne sur monsieur collet
certainement à juste titre que je ne
connais aussi une partie de son parcours
mais voilà on parlait de salaire du
front républicain je crois que c'est
mehdi barbeau qui ont parlé
en effet entre les deux tours on sait
que monsieur villiers a rejoint monsieur
coller avec d'autres pour se lier
ensemble contre le front national ont
déjà voilà après se dire qu'on est plus
copains qu'on s'attaque du raïs l'atvs
mais c'est moi rire et on sait aussi que
monsieur villiers a recruté pour en
marche la candidats de la troisième
circonscription donc interprétation très
personnelle
c'est faire peu de cas madame de
l'engagement politique est terminée on
n'aura jamais quitté l'italie pour une
petite ville cancer je tiens à préciser
que je ne critique pas du tout une femme
bien au contraire je trouve qu'il manque
eu bien des femmes au niveau de la
politique au niveau de la
circonscription c'est vrai que l'on a
une très grande circonscription qui
souffre de bien des maux comme vous
l'avez dit
qu'est ce que vous proposez alors mois
déjà il est important du jeu au niveau
de la santé de ramener des médecins il
faut aussi pour ça il faut aussi au
niveau de l'internât des médecins les
obliger à venir faire déjà des stages
dans nos ruralité pour essayer de les
inviter à venir chez nous il faut aussi
réintervenir hausse niveau de la sortie
de l'école en donnant un classement
puisque souvent les médecins ils
s'installent dans les grandes villes
pourquoi est-ce que je vais pas dire
qu'ils ont des horaires facile c'est pas
du tout ça
mais voilà la clientèle est là y'a pas à
se déplacer c'est elle qui vient dans
les campagnes c'est vrai que c'est
différent dans les campagnes il ya des
gens qui peuvent se déplacer il y en a
d'autres qui peuvent pas il faut aller
les voir et ça je comprends que c'est
beaucoup d'heures pour un médecin
mais ce n'est pas parce qu'on a décidé
d'aller habiter à la campagne qu'on n'a
pas le droit on ne dit pas comment voilà
le problème à 6 ballons vous nous dites
qu'il ya des problèmes d'horreur pour
les médecins je vous ai parlé je vous ai
parlé de l'internât des médecins les
obliger à faire un stage et je vous ai
parlé de réglementer la sortie de
l'internât des médecins en faisant un
classement pour les obliger
selon leur classement à aller partout en
france deux mesures
voilà au delà on avance donc il ne reste
plus beaucoup de temps au delà terminé
puisque les départs vont au delà de cet
aspect santé des médecins généralistes
ou spécialistes
il ya aussi le problème de l'hôpital
puisque aujourd'hui on a quand même un
hôpital à avallon il à tonnerre qui
aujourd'hui n'ont plus grand chose à
proposer pour les gens fous c'est
relativement restreint mais que fait
voilà vous n'avez plus de maternité n'y
a plus de service pédiatrique
il ya eu aucun incident d'ailleurs le
signal j'en suis bien heureuse encore
heureux mais je trouve dommage
aujourd'hui les femmes et les enfants ne
puissent pas bénéficier de ce service au
plus près j'ai aujourd'hui ils sont
suivis par le centre de périnatalité
allait obliger de rouler parce qu'on
arrive bientôt la fin d'émission avait
fait honneur à la famille du trésor
tarde par les femmes excusez moi mais
des barbeaux très très en fleurs donc
notre répond clairement à votre question
vous avez fait une bonne analyse de
notre circonscription
il ya globalement la nar si la ville
d'avalon
qui est on peut considérer comme une
ville mais je trouve que même les
communes comme saint florentin migennes
et tonnerre sont des communes où il ya
quand même assez peu d'habitants donc
c'est un ds est une circonscription très
rurale et a même beaucoup plus de petits
villages moins de 2000 habitants
sur la circonscription et moi je tiens à
répondre à ces petits villages via
l'état généraux de la ruralité qui ne
qui a été qui a été fait lors de la
présidentielle et pour la législative
pour faire entendre leur voix
il se trouve que le monde rural donne
beaucoup à la france est aujourd'hui ils
attendent la france je serai ce député
qui répond au monde rural car c'est
parti avec une épine qu'ils ont eue dans
le pied avec la loi notre ça c'est une
catastrophe pour notre petit qu'une
petite campagne et toute la bourgogne
doit donc en est tributaire je pense que
c'est toi notes pour faire 60 millions
d'économies à tout donner à
l'intercommunalité alors il ya beaucoup
de gens qui diront ah oui non mais c'est
bien ça rassemble non parce que ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher
il ya moins d'être pour les petites
communes et il se trouve que maintenant
avoir 30 ans avoir un ou deux enfants et
habiter dans un petit village on a du
mal à trouver du boulot on a du mal à se
déplacer
on a du mal à aller via l'e commerce
donc pour un pays comme la france je
trouve ça quand même très désertique et
il est grand temps de faire quelque
chose pour nous pour notre petite
commune et les métiers les métiers
autour de ces petites communes
l'agriculture excusez moi et j'en
termine les métiers autour de ces
petites communes c'est l'agriculture et
la viticulture et d'autres secteurs
d'activité comme le btp qui marche ce
qui marchait aussi avant dans notre
département je souhaite se voir
dégringoler que vous on est en train de
dépasser de dépasser tous nos équilibres
et bercé la fin de l'émission et il est
temps de conclure dans l'ordre qui ont
attiré préalablement au sort avant cette
émission donc 30 secondes par personne
oui j'aime moi je tiens à préciser que
le front national est la candidate que
je représentais de vigie à quai je suis
vraiment la seule candidate à
l'opposition des propositions de
monsieur macron que ce soit monsieur
coller ça tout le monde le sait et
soutient monsieur macron ça c'est pas
une nouveauté pas content
monsieur villiers c'est un leurre par
rapport à son mandat par rapport à cette
candidature aux législatives et le front
national est vraiment le seul qui
souhaitent s'opposer à la con merci et
vive jacquet andré villiers a coûté
conclure en forme de question j'ai envie
d'interroger tous les candidats qui sont
autour de cette table
j'ai apprécié leur nom mais ça fait rien
mais au moins s'ils connaissent la
retraite de base d'un d'une conjointes
d'exploitants agricoles de commerçants
ou d'artisans je pose la question et
vous ne répondrez tout à l'heure les
petites retraites pour moi ça constitue
une véritable la dignité nationale et
c'est le sujet de leur revalorisation
est un sujet majeur et le sujet de
l'urgence
alors je sais pas s'ils rencontrent les
mêmes personnes dans nos campagnes mais
un grand nombre de nos concitoyens et
bien vivent avec moins de 800 euros par
mois quand certains parlementaires
vivent avec 800 euros par jour par jour
donc il faudrait il faudrait donc il
faudrait peut-être mettre un terme à ces
excès à ses excès et toute ressemblance
évidemment avec une situations
existantes ou ayant existé serait
fortuite ou ou coïnciderait avec autre
chose
et en conclusion eh bien je dis que
c'est pas le moment de redonner la clés
du camion à celui qui l'a mis dans le
fossé oui on a affaire un spécialiste il
faut puisque on parler de ruralité re
revenir sur le le retard abyssal de
l'yonne dont le conseil départemental
que vous présidez et responsable en
matière de numérique et ça fera partie
des priorités du plan d'investissement
comme en matière de téléphonie puisque
c'est la loi macron qui a commencé à
déverrouiller le système il faut
revaloriser le minimum vieillesse 100
euros par mois
c'est dans le programme de la règle de
la république en marge il faut également
continuer de conforter nos hôpitaux qui
s'équipent en matière de diagnostic et
d'urgence qui accueil des internes qui
accueillent les stagiaires et le numerus
clausus sera élargi pour permettre des
installations un site est justement là
où nous avons besoin alors les 11 et 18
juin prochains
il ne s'agit pas d'un troisième tour
d'une revanche je laisse les polémiques
personnel et la fuite devant débats de
fond à ceux dont c'est le métier
ne nous trompons pas de débat il faut
une majorité à ce jeune président qui
portent haut les couleurs de la france
et qui porte l'espoir de la réponse
arrive que la file moi je encore une
fois je m'amuse que les deux précédents
intervenants qui ont supporté
où voter les deux quinquennats précédent
face aujourd'hui un constat d'une
situation dramatique
effectivement la situation est
dramatique mais en portent eux seuls la
responsabilité pour le soutien qu'il
apporte au gouvernement la question
sociale est une question fondamentale
l'augmentation des revenus des plus
faibles les plus fermes où le vent dotée
aujourd'hui est un impératif et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la candidature de jean
luc mélenchon travers du programme
d'avenir en commun pose effectivement
toutes ces questions et les réponses
communes entend y apporter
merci merci beaucoup françois méro donc
moi je pense qu'il faut élire un député
qui fasse entendre la voix du peuple à
l'assemblée nationale qui combattent la
politique que veut mettre en oeuvre le
président de la république mais aussi
celle de la droite et qui commence par
exemple par la volonté de casser le code
du travail par ordonnance cet été
ensuite je pense qu'il faut défendre les
services publics moi j'ai toujours été
j'ai été de tous les combats dans cette
circonscription pour défendre le service
public le lycée de michel qui a fermé
mais aussi les suppressions de postes
dans l'éducation nationale
les suppressions d'arrêt de gares de
trains sur les lignes du morvan sncf
évidemment je pense que la candidature
que je représente est celle du
rassemblement à gauche dans la
continuité du vote pour jean luc
mélenchon mais aussi des électeurs qui
se sont retrouvés sur la candidature de
benoît hamon parce que il était en
rupture avec la politique de françois
hollande
merci en soi mais rod mais les barreaux
c'est beaucoup alors moi ma candidature
sera je serai opérationnel le 19 juin
pour être le député des icaunais via
pour porter le projet de notre famille
politique à ce qu'ils voient à
rassembler les patriotes et les
républicains re donner tout ce qu'on a
proposé via la présidentielle à notre
programme en français c'est à dire les
services publics la médecine de
proximité
le développement des infrastructures
j'aurai un mandat où je serai dévoué où
je serai présent sur la circonscription
et je tiens à dire que dès que possible
j'aurais deux permanences sur la
circonscription pour répondre aux
attentes des défaites des icaunais une
fois par semaine merci mais l'ibère beau
merci à tous les 6 avant de nous séparer
doit mentionner que sont aussi candidats
sur cette circonscription joël rigolât
pour le fpf à nice cannes ighli à carnac
pour le bo idée frédéric back aubiac
pour l'upm cyril ray coquet nicolas
robert et le dit roy pour le prg
guillaume durand christophe la mode hier
anita carrasco pour lutte ouvrière et
dursun stade pour le p e j merci à tous
les six d'être venus débattre
merci stéphane mercier
avec nous pour cette journée position
bon dimanche
au revoir
[Musique]